caroline mécary bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
on l'a vu des actions innovantes ont été
mises en place par les robes noires un
peu partout en france ce vendredi à la
grève a été reconduite pour une semaine
à ce que les avocats ont le pouvoir de
tenir dans la durée
les avocats ont parfaitement le pouvoir
de tenir dans la durée je rappelle que
le conseil national des barreaux qui est
notre organe représentatif et celui qui
a appelé à nouveau aujourd'hui à une
nouvelle semaine de grève pourquoi nous
faisons même nous faisons grève parce
que le gouvernement n'entend pas nos
revendications légitimes comme l'a
rappelé le bâtonnier de bordeaux
nos cotisations sociales vont doubler et
notre retraite va passer de 1400 euros
par mois à 1000 euros
par ailleurs nous avons cotisé et nous
avons mis en réserve ses cotisations
pour payer les pensions et le
gouvernement veut confisquer ses
réserves qui sont de 2 milliards il ya
là une véritable spoliation de ce que
nous avons cotisé
donc nous tiendront jusqu'au bout alors
on a bien en entendu à ce que cette
réforme des retraites changera
concrètement pour les avocats où en sont
aujourd'hui vos discussions avec le
gouvernement et en particulier avec la
garde des sceaux nicole belloubet c'est
très simple la garde des sceaux fait de
la poudre de perlimpinpin
c'est à dire qu'elle n'a absolument rien
proposé de concret elle a programmé la
disparition de notre caisse autonome
autonome ça veut dire qu' il n'y a que
nous avocats qui sommes des professions
libérales qui cotisons à notre propre
retraite nous ne demandons aucun argent
contribuables aucun argent à l'état et
en plus chaque année notre caisse
reverse 100 millions d'euros aux autres
caisses de retraite qui elles sont
déficitaires
donc la garde
sow a fait comme sienne nous entendait
mais en réalité c'est qu'elle nous à la
lettre qu'elle nous a adressé est une
fin de non recevoir
est ce que vous pensez sérieusement que
les 70000 avocats du barreau de paris
que le conseil national des barreaux
appellerait depuis hier à une nouvelle
journée de grève
si nous avions été le moins du mans
entendu il ya de nouvelles actions qui
sont en préparation la semaine prochaine
parce qu'il est intolérable d'avoir des
pouvoirs publics qui méprise autant
notre profession mais nous ne sommes pas
la seule à être méprisé tout le monde
est méprisée dans cette réforme des
retraites
les femmes vont être particulièrement
pénalisées par cette nouvelle réforme
des retraites et ce n'est pas beaucoup
de bien qu'il ya une contestation
sociale qui est extrêmement brand dans
ce pays et ce n'est pas pour rien que le
président m'a prend aujourd'hui un
président d'un état démocratique ne peut
même plus se rendre à un théâtre sans
être hué et houspiller cela veut dire
véritablement qu'il ya une surdité de
l'appareil d'état qui est gravissime
et croyez moi les avocats ce ne sont pas
des extreme 2 d'affreuses extrémistes de
gauche
ce sont des gens extrêmement respectueux
de la loi si nous en sommes là c'est
vraiment parce que la coupe est pleine
et que cette réforme va aboutir à la
disparition programmée d'un tiers les
70000 avocat c'est à dire la disparition
dans les territoires de ses avocats qui
au quotidien vous devant les
juridictions défendent les justiciables
les plus les plus modestes que les plus
précaires à l'aide juridictionnelle
eh bien nous disons ça suffit ac nous ne
sommes pas des paillassons caroline
mécary à ce que le dialogue est
totalement rompu roux est ce qu'il y ait
encore des portes qui peuvent s'ouvrir
selon vous alors de notre point de vue
nous sommes absolument prêt à dialoguer
mais en face on fait semblant de viale
gay c'est à dire qu'on nous prend pour
des imbéciles
c'est à dire que nous n'avons absolument
aucune garantie de ce que les avocats ne
vont pas payer plus cher pour une
pension
diminués nous n'avons aucune garantie de
ce que ces deux milliards de réserves
qui sont déjà les cotisations que nous
avons versé ne soient pas captés pour la
collectivité et qu' il ne nous reste
rien pour prévoir les pensions de demain
donc en réalité la malle elle est
aujourd'hui dans le camp des pouvoirs
publics et plus précisément cette
question ne peut pas être tranchée
autrement que politiquement c'est la
raison pour laquelle le cnb a demandé à
être reçu par edward fils le conseil des
barreaux au conseil national des
barreaux n'arrêtera pas grave et nous
n'arrêterons pas la crème tant que le
premier ministre ne nous aura pas
entendu ne nous aura pas reçu évidemment
il ne s'agit pas qui nous reçoit pour
dire je vous ai reçu comme il a fait
avec et les uns et les autres mais il
s'agit l'entendre nous sommes dans une
situation différente de celle des
fonctionnaires et de celle des salariés
nous sommes des professions libérales
nous n'avons pas d'employeur notre
situation différente justifie un
traitement différent de la même manière
qu'eux aujourd'hui ils les policiers
vont avoir un régime différent
les pompiers vont avoir un régime
différent parce qu'ils sont dans une
situation différente d'exercice
professionnel des autres salariés et des
autres fonctionnaires nous réclamons
donc le maintien de notre caisse
autonome
parce que nous sommes dans une situation
juridique différente
merci beaucoup caroline mécary d'avoir
accepté de répondre à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes avocate au
barreau de paris